how's it going people uh no I'm not in
Miami in the Free State of Florida I'm
in San Francisco in communist California
I have good reasons to be here I
apologize that we had no live show
yesterday and there'll be no live show
today I'm pre-taping this just because I
wanted you guys to know that I'm not
abandoning you I just want you to trust
me there are good reasons that I'm here
I would not come back to this state if
it didn't wasn't about good reason so
trust me on that so I'm just wandering
aimlessly at the moment and I got a
meeting in a couple hours and basically
it's a pretty much a ghost town this
whole place and when you do see people
they seem to be either buying or selling
drugs or looking for someone to buy or
sell drugs so that's some great work
they're doing here in California
anyway hang tight
back on Monday I promise you good things
happening trust me
and and pray for me also thank you
goodbye
just enjoy myself day here in San
Francisco beautiful Town nice weather
everything seems just fine and you know
just uh you know having fun okay yeah
you know just enjoying bye-bye